(film whirring)
- [Host] The Crown Season
3 kicks off in 1964,
17 years after the start of Season 1.
Now, that's a lot of history.
The season ushers in a new era
of Beatles, silver jubilees
and moon landings.
The Queen is now rapidly
approaching her 40s,
Charles and Anne are coming of age
and Britain is a very different place.
Whether you're after a refresh
or are brand new to The Crown
and want to jump straight
in, this video is for you.
We're not recapping
everything that happens
in Season 1 and 2, just
the key parts of the story
that have a big impact on Season 3.
Quick reminder, the timeline
of The Crown is factual,
but it is a drama.
So while The Crown is
meticulously researched,
some creative license is used
to drive the personal stories.
Season 3 sees Elizabeth
contemplate the life
she could have had
if she'd never become queen.
Because if you remember,
she was never really
meant to wear the crown.
Her uncle, Edward VIII, great
grandson of icon, legend
and star Queen Victoria
ascended the throne
after the death of his father.
However, in a shock twist
only the British monarchs
know how to serve, Edward
abdicated that same year
because he wanted to marry
an American divorcee named Wallis Simpson.
- [Royal] His love for her
has destroyed everything.
- It is love.
- [Host] You see, as the
King of the United Kingdom,
he was also Head of the Church
and marrying a divorcee
was out of the question.
So he chose love and moved to France.
There's a Madonna movie all
about it for those interested.
But what does that mean for Elizabeth?
Now, with Edward gone,
his little brother Albert
who had lived in his
brother's shadow until now
stepped up to become King George VI.
With a new king came a
new heir, enter Elizabeth.
Okay, let's fast forward to 1947.
Princess Elizabeth
marries Philip Mountbatten
in a super understated ceremony.
In The Crown, we see Philip portrayed
as a very proud man.
He struggles from the off when it comes
to joining the royal family
and being second to his wife.
That's the dynamic he
continues to struggle with
throughout the show.
Though, as he approaches
middle age in Season 3,
we see his concerns shift
slightly as he comes to terms
with having lived a life of duty
rather than a life of passion.
After marrying, Elizabeth and
Philip have four children,
Charles, Anne, Andrew and Edward.
In 1952, King George VI dies
following a lung cancer diagnosis.
Elizabeth, who remember
was never really meant
to become queen, does just that.
At George's funeral, we see
his older brother return
to the UK, which caused quite the pickle.
More than a year later
and it's time for Elizabeth
to be crowned queen.
When we see this period in
The Crown, we see Philip
ask to be excused from bowing
to his wife at her coronation
and asks that his children
not lose the name Mountbatten.
After some back and forths,
both answered with a big resounding...
- No.
- [Host] Now that we have our
queen, this is a good time
to remind you that she
had a younger sister,
a younger sister who lived
in her older sister's shadow.
Sound familiar?
In Season 3, we see Margaret
step into the spotlight
very publicly and here
are some iconic limericks
along the way.
- And that asshole in Buckingham Palace.
(laughing)
- [Host] But we're also
seeing a woman dealing
with marriage woes and
forever being second fiddle.
Jumping back to the '40s
and '50s, Margaret was often
said to be the louder, more
rambunctious of the sisters.
She's certainly a lot of fun in The Crown.
And when she deputizes for the Queen
and goes totally off script...
- Our ambassador to the
United States of America,
Sir Roger Makins,
the only honest thing to
come out of Washington.
- [Host] She causes a stir with people
including the Prime
Minister Winston Churchill
and the Queen herself.
That defiance of protocol
continues in the new season.
In 1953, Margaret became
involved with Peter Townsend
a former RAF Officer and
later Queen's Equerry.
The public loved their relationship.
- [Reporter] Pressmen and sightseers
hoping for a glimpse of the couple.
- [Host] But Townsend is a divorcee,
which as we've learned is less than ideal.
Long story short, the Church, Parliament
and other senior royals do
not approve of the union.
Townsend is sent away and
ultimately the relationship ends.
(classical music)
Despite promising to never love again,
Margaret eventually pairs
up with a fairly nice,
fairly boring man named Billy Wallace,
but eventually breaks it off.
In a very Love Island move,
Margaret then picks a
sexy bad boy photographer
named Antony Armstrong Jones.
We see it all go down in Season 2
when he was taking
official portraits of her
and true to form, she went loge
and sent a seemingly
naked photo of herself
to the UK tabloids.
- [Reader] And she's naked.
- [Host] A lot of hoo-ha
later and eventually in 1960,
the two got married and went
on to have two children.
Keep an eye on that particular union.
It's a big and messy
plot point in Season 3.
There are a couple of really
incredible episodes in Season 3
that focus on Prince Charles
and his coming of age.
In Season 2, we saw his father struggle
with a seemingly sensitive child.
- So we're not just becoming
a wet mandy-pandy monarchy twit.
- [Host] Philip believed his
own upbringing made him tough.
So the same needed to be
true of his eldest son.
We saw Charles struggle when
his father insisted he attend
Gordonstoun School and the two continue
to have a troubled relationship
now that Charles is growing up.
(light music)
Back to the Queen for a sec,
our story has seen some ups
and downs in her marriage over the years.
- Philip, don't you get ever back here!
- [Host] The power dynamic
with Philip is a key thing
to keep in your mind and
we've watched it play out
across many episodes.
The two are arguably
more settled in Season 3.
And we see some real moments of love.
But there's no denying
Philip is a complex character
with a lot of baggage.
The other thing to note
is the way her stoicism
is portrayed in the show.
When she met Jackie Kennedy in
Season 2, we saw her ability
to deal with bad behavior
in a proper fashion.
Where others might have
screamed and shouted...
- I'm quite sure that you
meant no harm nor disrespect.
After all, why would you?
- [Host] In Season 3, we
see key moments in her life
when you may expect a
more emotional response
but after years of being on the throne,
she's learned as Margaret put it...
- Camera perfect.
- [Host] That's pretty
much you need to know
about our story thus far.
There are a few other things
you should probably know
about the UK in the 1960s,
one of which is the swing
to liberal politics.
The Conservative Party had
been hit by a sex scandal,
the Profumo Affair for those interested.
And that as well as a
growing liberal movement
across the country led to a small
Labor majority win in 1964.
We see some of the ups and downs
of the politics in Season 3.
So we won't show a load of spoilers,
but with the growing liberal
movement came a renewed sense
of anti-monarchy sentiment
across the nation.
It's fascinating to see how
it plays out in Season 3.
- They want our heads on stakes.
- [Host] One more thing
and then we'll leave you to it, miners.
The struggle of the miners
in 1960s and '70s Britain
is well documented.
We had a national coal board
trying to keep costs down
and a national union of mine workers
who wanted increased
wages, fairer working hours
and a change to safety
conditions, among other things.
The two got into many
disputes over the years.
In Season 3, we'll see our monarchy react.
Finally, meet our cast.
We're 17 years ahead by now
and everybody is a bit older.
In fact, the Queen herself is in her 50s
by the end of Season 3.
Olivia Colman is wearing the
crown as Queen Elizabeth II,
Helena Bonham Carter is playing Margaret,
and we have Tobias
Menzies as Prince Philip.
Ben Daniels plays Tony Armstrong
Jones, Margaret's husband.
Charles Dance is Lord
Mountbatten, Philip's uncle.
Marion Bailey is the Queen Mother,
while Josh O'Connor and Erin Doherty
play Prince Charles and
Princess Anne respectively.
Okay, we're done.
You're all caught up.
Watch The Crown now streaming on Netflix.